on me demande très souvent comment
est-ce qu'on peut accéder aux
communautés comment on peut aller
visiter des communautés
ça peut être une question assez délicate
parce que c'est quand même je dirais
même si je veux aller visiter çà et là
est-ce que je rentrais chez quelqu'un
lui demandait par mois de salaire par
mois ta culture c'est c'est la même
chose dans les communautés ou dans les
réserves ou même d'aller dans les
organismes en milieu urbain faut pas
oublier que on est les programmations
mais on vient pour monde avec le devoir
ou l'obligation même des fois le goût
d'expliquer tout le temps notre culture
à tout le monde mais on n'aime que les
gens s'intéressent à notre culture donc
il faut choisir des moments et des
portes d'entrée pour rentrer dans les
communautés le meilleur meilleur accès
jeudi temps assez les parois ou aux
paroles c'est un moment qui est ouvert à
tout le monde que tu sois autochtones
non autochtone c'est un moment de fête
c'est vraiment ce que tu peux acheter de
l'artisanat manger la nourriture locale
c'est le temps d'aller dans une
communauté quand vous voyez pas worth et
pas uniquement pour les gens de la
communauté c'est pour tout le monde
alors c'est le temps d'y aller et
d'apprendre avec respect la culture de
plusieurs nations qui sont l'un qui
échange entre l on a aussi des
événements qui vont être moins liés sur
la culture mais des fois ça peut être
des tournois de hockey ça peut être des
festivals de musique comme il nous nous
comme aux amalgames il ya des moments
d'échangés culturels ou d'activités
sportives qui sont ouverts à tout le
monde
des fois par exemple il ya des moments
où ce que on demande au public notre
tournoi ceux qui n'ont pas été vite de
ne pas aller aux événements que ça peut
être des grands rassemblements ou même
de se promener dans le village les vite
monté comme si c'étaient les 800
policiers on regarde les programmations
c'est pas comme ça qu'on va se faire des
amis alors le meilleur manière c'est
souvent de créer une relation avec un
individu qui votent invité chez lui
comme n'importe quel québécois frais
pour faire visiter sa localité où sa
ville et après ça quand c'est fait dans
le respect quand c'est fait sur du long
terme petit peu juste après s'être
développé d'autres amitiés découvrir la
nation et la culture et la communauté
d'une façon beaucoup plus saine que si
on faisait un joug
propos logique donc j'espère que vous
allez pas hésité de partager des moments
que vous avez apprécié justement quand
vous êtes allés dans des communautés et
vous allez pas hésité non plus à prendre
des risques parce que c'est que c'est ça
peut être intimidant
le premier contact avec une nouvelle
culture surtout quand c'est une culture
qui a fait 500 ans avec laquelle vous
partager le territoire mais que vous
n'avez pas encore été visités
mais je peux vous dire que la personne
qui jamais venu me voir en disant
c'était la pire erreur de ma vie c'est
souvent le contraire qu'on dit donc
merci pour la question n'hésitez pas à
nous envoyer d'autres espaces autochtone
la parole autochtone et je vous souhaite
une très belle semaine